from a cast down clown to a nasty nurse
these TV roles are career highlights for
actors who typically stick to the Silver
Screen
thanks to his effortless charm Matthew
McConaughey became a star in romantic
comedies opposite Jennifer Lopez in The
Wedding Planner Sarah Jessica Parker in
Failure to Launch and Kate Hudson in How
to Lose a Guy in 10 Days and Fool's Gold
beginning in the 2010s McConaughey began
exploring his darker side with roles and
Prestige movie dramas he shed nearly 50
pounds for his oscar-winning performance
as an AIDS patient in the late jean-mark
valets Dallas Buyers Club but
McConaughey turned in one of the best
performances of his career in the first
season of Nick pizzolato's HBO crime
Anthology series True Detective he
played brilliant tortured detective rust
Cole a man investigating a series of
grisly murders in rural Louisiana world
needs bad man
foreign
from the door
[ __ ] McConaughey delivers an
unforgettable performance that's equal
parts charismatic and dangerous
with the filmography as rich as Laura
derns it's tough to pick her best work
her ongoing collaborations with David
Lynch are excellent options from her
breakthrough turn in the Suburban
nightmare blue velvet to her tour de
force performance in the mind-bending
Inland Empire Dern's finest work over
the course of her five decade career is
always marked by a willingness to dive
into her character's uglier sides she
achieves this best as amygelico in HBO's
dramedy series enlightened the
well-intentioned but destructive Jellico
suffers a nervous breakdown attends
rehab then returns home to pick up the
pieces with a fresh spiritually evolved
perspective over the course of two
critically acclaimed but underwatch
Seasons Dern explores the intersection
of Amy's unpredictable rage and blazing
altruism Dern's Golden Globe winning
performance as Jellico kicked off what
Vox labeled the dernisons leading to her
Explosive Performance in big little lies
and culminating in her oscar-winning
turn in Noah bombach's marriage story
Taraji P Henson first attracted
attention for her role in John
Singleton's 2001 dramedy baby boy but
her breakthrough performance was in
Craig Brewer's 2005 crime drama Hustle
and Flow opposite Terence Howard as
pregnant sex worker shook Hinson offered
audiences a first Glimpse at her
signature blend of tough love and biting
wit those qualities would Define her
work for years to come
and Now work like a dog day and night
living off a coffee from a pot none of
you want to touch
Henson earned an Oscar nom for her
Tinder performance in David Fincher's
drama The Curious Case of Benjamin
Button as Benjamin's adoptive mother
however she delivered the performance of
her career as cookie Lyon in Fox's music
business series Empire as the ex-wife of
hip-hop mogul Lucius played by former
co-star Terence Howard Henson delivers
an electrifying performance acting as if
Lady Macbeth were cast on the Real
Housewives critics noticed Henson earned
three Emmy nominations and a Golden
Globe over the course of the show's six
seasons
as an actor Justin Thoreau can
effortlessly see-saw between satirical
comedies like Zoolander and crime dramas
like the girl on the train however his
first big screen moment came in 1997's
Romy and Michelle's High School reunion
a short scene with Janine Garofalo
illustrates the rose smoldering heat and
impeccable timing Thoreau went on to
epitomize the entitled jerk delivering
strong supporting performances as an 80s
investment banker in American Psycho and
a petulant director under the thumb of
the mob in Mulholland Drive but it
wasn't until Damon lindelof's epic
series The Leftovers debuted on HBO in
2014 that we saw the full scope of
thoreau's range as tortured police chief
Kevin Garvey Thoreau delivers the best
work of his career
[Music]
times you have to pretend
his performance grounds the sprawling
drama as it evolves from season 1 story
of family trauma to something scratching
at the philosophical Cosmos in the third
and final season
in the 1980s Rob Lowe built a reputation
for playing disaffected Bad Boys in
coming-of-age dramas in films like
Francis Ford Coppola's The Outsiders and
Joel Schumacher's Saint Elmo's Fire over
the following 30 years Lowe's roles have
ranged from slapstick comedy in Wayne's
World Tommy Boy and the Austin Powers
Trilogy to prestige TV drama like The
West Wing of course his best work came
when he joined season two of NBC's Parks
and Recreation as type a fitness fanatic
Chris Trager who may or may not be
responsible for the uptick in people
saying literally literally all the time
my body is finely tuned like a microchip
and the flu is like a grain of sand it
could literally shut down the entire
system low infuses Chris's unwavering
optimism with an endearing charm that
never feels oppressive an on-screen feat
few but low can pull off
Zach galifianakis's Big Break came with
Todd Phillips raunchy 2009 comedy The
Hangover as the quirky and unpredictable
Allen Galifianakis stole every scene
from better known co-stars Bradley
Cooper at Helms and Justin bartha he
cultivated his unique brand of socially
awkward humor with memorable turns in
Alejandro in yaritus Birdman and two
more installments of The Hangover
trilogy but Galifianakis gives the best
performance of his career in fx's
underrated dramedy baskets as identical
twins Chip and Dale baskets Galifianakis
is in his element as ruthless delusional
chip an aspiring artist who fails out of
clown School in France and is forced to
return home and accept work as a rodeo
clown in Bakersfield California
after an impressive career in Australian
movies as a teenager Nicole Kidman Rose
to International Fame with Tony Scott's
1990 action thriller Days of Thunder
alongside her soon-to-be husband Tom
Cruise you're fine put on your clothes
over the ensuing three decades Kidman
proved to be a versatile movie star with
four Academy Award nominations for
Moulin Rouge Rabbit Hole lion and being
the Ricardos and one win for the hours
Kidman's performances walk a thin line
between raw vulnerability and Poise that
quality is best exemplified in her turn
as retired lawyer Celeste Wright in
HBO's big little lies Celeste leads a
seemingly perfect life with her wealthy
family in Monterey California but
beneath the facade lies an awful secret
she's being abused by her husband Kidman
imbues Celeste trauma with complexity
and contradiction rarely seen in
domestic violence dramas
Gabby Hoffman managed the rare feat of
growing her career from successful child
actor through adolescence and into
adulthood she first made a name for
herself opposite Kevin Costner and Amy
Madigan in Field of Dreams and the late
John Candy and Uncle Buck as a teenager
she appeared in big budget films like
disaster Thriller volcano as well as
Independence like 200 Cigarettes and you
can count on me her Indie work led to
roles in highbrow comedy series
including the performance of her career
on Amazon's groundbreaking dramedy
transparent as the ever Restless Ali
pfefferman youngest sibling of LA's
neurotic feferman Clan Hoffman is a
revelation she infuses her
confrontational and prickly yet
sensitive character with open-hearted
Grace as Ali yearns to understand their
family Legacy and their place within it
Maggie Gyllenhaal is a multifaceted
performer with a diverse list of credits
including Blockbusters like The Dark
Knight iconic Indie secretary and the
award-winning drama crazy heart in 2021
she added screenwriter and director to
her resume with the critically acclaimed
adaptation of Elena ferrante's novel The
Lost daughter directing work aside
Gyllenhaal's finest role in front of the
camera is her performance as 1970s sex
worker turned porn filmmaker Andy in
HBO's the deuce
up really soon
Gyllenhaal plays candy with dignity
seldom afforded to sex worker characters
heightening the emotional Stakes as she
works her way up from the streets you
can't help but be moved as she achieves
the power Financial Security and
Independence she's fought for since
episode 1.
Steve Carell rocketed to stardom with
his performance in Adam McKay's Smash
Hit Anchorman the Legend of Ron Burgundy
as Rick Tamlin The Eccentric
meteorologist with an IQ of 48 Carell
introduced his comedic wheelhouse to the
world the cringy hapless fool he went on
to perfect his style in his first
leading role in Judd Apatow's the 40
year old virgin but reached his Apex in
his iconic turn as Michael Scott on
NBC's The Office in the first season
Corel mimicked Ricky gervais's character
David Brent on the BBC's version of the
show as the series continued Corel
infused Michael Scott with more empathy
making him one of the more endearing if
incompetent sitcom characters in recent
memory even as he shifts to more
dramatic roles it is difficult to
imagine Corel ever topping Michael Scott
would I rather be feared or loved
um easy both
I want people to be afraid of how much
they love me
as a young actress in the 90s Christina
Ricci Rose to fame with a string of
popular family movies including The
Adams Family The Adams Family Values and
Casper Richie went on to play elusive
heroines in Darker films earning Indie
clout for her turns and Don Rue's black
comedy the opposite of sex and Vincent
Gallows Bleak surrealist drama Buffalo
66 as her movie career continued Ricci
was frequently overshadowed by her
co-stars from Johnny Depp and Tim
Burton's Sleepy Hollow to Charlize
Theron in Monster ultimately Richie
turned to the small screen taking on a
variety of complicated women from
history like Zelda Fitzgerald Nelly Bly
an ax murderous Lizzie Borden however
the best role of Richie's career is that
of sociopath nurse Misty in Showtime's
hit drama Yellowjackets as Misty Richie
fuses the wholesome innocence of her
early work with the creepy Menace of her
later performances
Kate Winslet enjoys Taking Chances early
in her career she chose roles that
demonstrated range which kept her from
being Typecast she made her audacious
debut as a murderous teenager in Peter
Jackson's Heavenly Creatures then
tackled Jane Austen in Sense and
Sensibility Shakespeare in 1996's Hamlet
and followed it up with Titanic despite
the fame that came with Titanic Winslet
continued to stretch herself resulting
in seven Oscar nominations and an
overdue win for the reader
he's grown up killed
but the best and most challenging role
of her career came in HBO's miniseries
mayor of East Town as a dogged
Philadelphia detective investigating a
murder Winslet Minds Pathos and humor
from the bleakest of circumstances as a
result she rightfully won best actress
of the SAG Awards Golden Globes Critics
Choice Awards and the prime time Emmys
Winslet's mare is a performance that
lingers with you long after the case is
closed Jeff Daniels is a standout in all
of his films from high-end dramas like
Pleasantville and Steve Jobs two less
distinguished outings like Dumb and
Dumber and Dumb and Dumber too over his
four decade career Daniels has proven he
can handle any genre he first appeared
on the big screen in milosh Foreman's
1981 period drama Ragtime in a minor
role as a police officer two years later
Daniel's career took flight with James L
Brooks oscar-winning tearjerker Terms of
Endearment he played flap the young
impulsive college professor who marries
the vivacious Emma played by Deborah
Winger as flap Daniels tapped into the
messiness of his character's life he
perfected this sensibility in his most
impressive movie performance in Noah
bombach's 2005 dark comedy the squid and
the whale Daniels plays a pretentious
jealous English professor in denial
about the breakdown of his family but
the performance of Daniel's career came
in Aaron sorkin's love it or hate it HBO
drama series The Newsroom
well our constitution is a masterpiece
James Madison was a genius the
Declaration of Independence is for me
the single greatest piece of American
writing
[Music]
for will McAvoy delivering sorkin's
monologues with a hair-raising intensity
that is part Shakespearean actor part
Carnival Barker despite all that Daniels
manages to render him human earning
three Emmy nominations and one win for
his bravado work
Steve Buscemi's prolific movie career
blossomed in a series of collaborations
with Joel and Ethan Cohen beginning with
1990s gangster drama Miller's crossing
over the next eight years busemi and the
Coen brothers collaborated on four
feature films Barton Fink the HUD sucker
proxy Fargo and The Big Lebowski
busimi's work with the cohens and his
performance as Mr Pink and Quentin
Tarantino's Reservoir Dogs honed his
reputation as one of the greater
character actors of all time
how do you do fellow kids busimi showed
a radically different side in Terry
zweigoff's offbeat Indie Ghost World as
Seymour a gentle Jazz Enthusiast who
becomes The Morbid Obsession of recent
High School grad Enid but he turned to
television for the best role of his
career Nucky Thompson and Terence
Winter's HBO prohibition drama Boardwalk
Empire busimi is mesmerizing as the
corrupt Atlantic City Treasurer playing
the well-deserved leading role in
complete Command of his craft
[Applause]
[Music]